et là on est en train de passer 6000 m²
la toiture d'un supermarché tout en
blanc on va éviter la surchauffe du
bâtiment on va réduire la température à
l'intérieur on va éviter qu'ils
utilisent la clim à l'intérieur donc les
gaz à effet de serre et voilà on va
faire un test et on va prendre une
température voilà donc on va être
au-delà de 40 si je commence à prendre
sur du blanc
là je suis à 20 degrés
salut je m'appelle Julien je fais partie
de l'entreprise de Coulomb France on va
monter effectivement dans un endroit que
personne ne voit en général nos visites
c'est la toiture du magasin le toit en
fait sa problématique c'est qu'il prend
énormément de chaleur
là on passe la première couche de ce
qu'on appelle le basecoat et en fait
c'est notre c'est la première couche de
notre peinture déjà cette heure-ci j'ai
quasiment divisé la température par deux
uniquement avec la première couche et on
n'a pas encore mis la deuxième couche
qui permet de tenir 20 ans et la
dernière couche qui va elle permet de
vraiment renvoyer continuer à renvoyer
les rayons du soleil
de l'été dernier qui a été vraiment un
élément déclencheur ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle un bitumineux c'est 70% du
marché en France sur les toitures
tertiaires il faut bien se dire qu'en
plein été ça ça va monter entre 70 et 90
degrés ça provoque la surchauffe à
l'intérieur et donc ça va impacter les
collaborateurs les visiteurs les
produits on va aller voir les rooftop
qui sont refroidis tout l'été à partir
de 30 degrés on doit les arroser et donc
c'est arroser 24 heures sur 24 7 jours
sur 7 du début de l'été jusqu'à la fin
de l'été ça permet d'avoir tout le
système de froid en bas ouais tous les
frigos pour que les gens puissent ne pas
avoir de rupture de la chaîne de froid
donc toute cette partie là sera peinte
en blanc parce que le nombre de mètres
cubes d'eau qu'on balance pour pas grand
chose c'est quand même dommage de
continuer à les balancer
c'est des millénaires d'expérience on
l'a déjà Santorin c'est une peinture
qu'on a développé qu'on a formulé par
nous-mêmes dedans on y a mis ça nous on
est on est à Brest qu'on remplace ces
charges calcaires dans la dans la
peinture par ça c'est de la coquille
d'huître tout simplement quand on le dit
aux gens ils nous disent on va vous
donner plein de coquilles 8 et tout ce
qu'on mange à Noël tout ce qu'on mange
on vous le garde et on vous le donne on
dit vous inquiétez pas il y a déjà
suffisamment de déchets il y a 130 000
tonnes par an qui sont consommés donc
nous on a besoin que de quelques tonnes
qui vous dit sur un toit comme ça que
tous les avantages dont tu as parlé ils
vont être effectifs et c'est pas du
théorique le premier bâtiment qu'on a
fait quand on a créé la société c'est
exactement le même que celui-là un
supermarché à Quimper 6000 m² et en fait
ça fait 9 ans qu'on le qu'on le suit
qu'on le trace on a donc divisé la
température par deux en surface on a
enlevé 5 à 6 à 7 degrés à l'intérieur du
bâtiment en mettant moins de clim ou
d'utilisation d'énergie on a baissé
entre 40 et 50% l'utilisation de
l'énergie dans le bâtiment on pourrait
se dire l'argent qu'on met dans cette
peinture blanche pourquoi ne pas la
mettre dans l'isolation tout est
complémentaire c'est là où on est de
nous à comprendre la gestion de la
thermie d'un bâtiment juste bien
souvenir qu'avec les prix que l'on
applique aujourd'hui 20 à 30 euros du
mètre carré fourni posé quand on regarde
les gains sur la clim ou les gains que
tu peux avoir en termes de confort
intérieur tu arrives à avoir des retours
sur investissement de l'ordre de 2 à 5
ans
du coup ça veut dire qu'on va faire
moins chaud on va devoir augmenter le
chauffage et ça c'est une espèce de je
vais pas dire de légende urbaine mais il
a fallu aller rentrer un peu dans la
technique et surtout rentrer dans les
instrumentsations qu'on met sur nos
sites pour arriver à démontrer que c'est
pas vrai en hiver c'est que c'est neutre
ou quasi neutre
on se rend pas forcément compte dans les
clims il y a des gaz HFC c'est des gaz
qui sont des milliers de fois plus
nocifs pour le climat que le CO2 en
peignant les toits en blanc on vient
limiter l'utilisation de ces fameux gaz
le but ultime c'est qu'il est cool rouge
partout dans le monde c'est que cette
innovation de peinture elle puisse
vraiment permettre de réduire des
millions de tonnes de gaz à effet de
serre imagine le GIEC effectivement qui
nous dit on va avoir deux trois quatre
degrés par la suite ça commence à
devenir effectivement flippant au final
nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est en faire un
modèle qui soit Open Source Open Source
parce que on veut que ça se répande
massivement de partout c'est-à-dire qu'à
un magasin une initiative comme ça si on
commence à la retrouver par 10 par 100
c'est là nous à notre modeste niveau où
on arrivera au moins à avoir des impacts
sur la décarbonation 36 kg de CO2 par
mètre carré en moins et sur le
rafraîchissement des des de la
surchauffe des bâtiments et donc des
îlots de chaleur urbain
[Musique]